hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast
whistleblower now people in the comments
below said that despite my efforts to
blur out what may have been gross hello
um this next part might even get worse
so I'm just gonna put a big warning
actually this is your warning in the
beginning of this that um if you are the
squeamish type you probably shouldn't be
watching outlast in the first place and
you should probably go watch some videos
of kittens playing in the field but if
you do want to keep watching um put on a
blindfold find an adult put on a ball
gag and let's have a fun ol time
oh where am I going okay so I don't know
what excuse me I don't know what's gonna
be even more gross good god your smile
is awesome oh you God that that explains
the old that 1920s radio music going on
back there God that guy was creepy okay
so they've done that uh the door trick
just to Oh
huh are you talking to me me you're
talking to me you talking to buddy you
better be talking to buddy don't make
any promises you can't keep big boy I I
have plenty of room
I have no emptiness inside me my heart
is filled with love the love of my fans
and apparently my wife said I need to
get back home too so no room for
anything else like a severed head whoa
always actually there so what do I do
hide hide hide is what I do
hey you don't do nothing I always
thought that was to Chris Walker farting
but apparently it's just that damn
sousaphone to buy my ear wants to keep
playing me tunes I don't have time for
your tunes I gotta get out of here from
this crazy great do you want to fill me
up oh god damn it I'm almost out of
batteries where do I go I don't know
where to go the place will oh we must
have open the door over there to get
over here ah I see well this is a
predicament ain't it
they seem to be almost out of batteries
and someone is to tear my giblets
straight from my belly
I don't think giblets come from the
belly but I'm not sure about anything
anymore this do sheer where did it go
may have to just sprint past him
I'm exercise to get them there one to go
but far
no no no no okay can't see can't see
can't see okay can't see I'm gonna run
out the guys saw something out of the
corner of my eye that I didn't like oh
good oh oh it's kind of okay never mind
what does that say love makes a house
home no no no no no get married son and
we'll see how happy okay push push bar
hurts like that of disgusting think I've
lured out if you guys want me to
describe it to you I can in vivid detail
I actually got a closer look at it was
even worse than I first thought
okay I like the scenery only you have to
look around till you find the right walk
for me right head to stuffin oh thank
you hey okay Jimmy here but a big ole
loser you huh oh this door right there
I should go I should hurry up and go and
stop taunting the big bad bad guy
because that would be dumb and stupid
and bad why is it blood all over this
who clobbered you push the thing I'll
push it the other way
did someone pick up this thing in the
clue no that's bad no that's bad no
that's bad
no that's bad run no that's bad okay
this way go go go go hit the ladder up
or down down I guess okay up I go okay
down I go up down
anta Ali okay that time that really hurt
thank you I don't know yes yes
absolutely
100% okay cool Cobain's that's a good
agreement so now I'm hobbled I do think
that I'm permanently crippled now Oh
what oh good I wasn't gonna be able to
make that ledge anyway let's get out
watch what happened no wait what what do
I do what Jamie what happened what did I
do
did I make the right or wrong choice I
don't know anymore a woman's work is
never done
Brooke ow my leg Howie kapowee was gonna
be bad isn't it this is gonna be bad bad
bad I can already tell oh hello that is
okay this is gonna there's no place like
home good good good good
looks like someone else hobbled we got a
piece of metal stuck in his ankle where
I'm gonna be joining up so do the death
row all I had another battery I didn't
think I did good good good good I just
need one more I need to follow the
blood-stained trail to get to where I
need to go okay
[Music]
was that supposed to happen no that was
not supposed to happen obviously one as
well seven let's just walk into death
waltz it willingly how do I get out of
here God where was I supposed to go
maybe there was another place up that I
didn't look okay you know what let's try
this one more time not failing horribly
because if I failed horribly then I'm oh
oh no no no no no no no God creepy ass
okay so the blood trail is actually
leading me to my own death but there has
to be some other way around here uh
which way do I go oh no no no he uh he
opens the door I'm supposed to hide I
gotta find a place to hide before he
gets me or else he's gonna get me and
then he's gonna kill me and he's gonna
rip out my giblets and then stuff me
fill of other people and that's not fun
is that oh that's a locker I can go in
God there was a locker right by the door
I was looking everywhere but what was
obvious okay cool yeah cool yeah suck on
this sprayer no I wasn't right what are
you doing a delicacy cool to be
unwrapped
okay yeah okay cool here we go
yay
wait a minute so ah that such ball god
damn it I was supposed to go in that I
knew I knew something was happening
where I was supposed to get me oh yeah I
want to say I'm sorry you're not
forgiven just you know how a man gets
well I mean I just want to say that may
have been some miscommunication here you
may be getting the wrong signals um
I am all man
a legacy should be the father I know
that I'll never let anything happen to
our children not like
well I mean that's great that's great
goals you got goals it's good to have
goals in life and it's good to be you
know a man you know who wants something
Emily it's great yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah good good good good good plan done
good
oh yeah I needed that I was a little
stressed out you know from the end
Saturday and I'm dead 12 hours later
what a nap Oh No yeah oh goodness
hi my friend ah bad luck that he caught
you too but I don't think he's in love
with you as much as with me I'm so sorry
love for everybody yeah I know
especially not you
I don't know what to do what expression
should I bake with my face I don't know
what to do with my hands okay
again with its ok good oh good golly oh
god like the worst kind of horror movie
they just make you what score's
splatterhouse loveliness oh boy oh no no
no no not me next
Oh as though it's got a torture you get
a watch what's gonna happen to you and
then it happens to you oh god all there
I am cool right you're going to be
beautiful I hope so I already am I want
to I want to make a point I already am
okay yeah yeah but you're there yeah
yeah yeah yeah but just try to enjoy
okay yes for what absolutely for the
sink nacho oh absolutely
okay absolutely a few snips of the flesh
here and yes cut away
vulgar Oh what are you talking about
soft place you're welcome mice and the
birthday is never easy
oh crap okay it's not even letting me
look away at this point
okay cool ah cool thank you sir thank
you sir okay okay okay okay sorry sorry
sorry darling [ __ ] that's good I'm
hobbling as fast as I can hobble for the
hell don't go oh come on come on die
aren't I but die Kent
I can't see a goddamn thing god damn it
get all the way hands and body part I
got places to be
thanks to say things to not be also like
God cut in half that's good my giblets
cut off literally this time finally the
direct meaning of what I was talking
about is actually expressed in the worst
way possible I can actually sleep better
without that some out of batteries
thought it picked up at least one but
apparently not apparently this guy
doesn't want to run after me got one
evident of that heroic guy that was just
smashing that guy in the face because I
hate that's why that's not the actually
yeah okay good good good good
oh goodness gracious these must have
been uh the rejects oh god oh god no no
yeah thank you
okay maybe maybe not we'll find out in a
second huh yeah we're gonna find out
real soon the limits of my darling miss
you never even saw me I am shattered
okay
alright I guess it doesn't even matter
[ __ ] backpack bag backpack
catch it close the door
keep it this way don't get caught on
crap all open that door I'm such an
idiot
I don't even see the door that's right
in front of my face running quickly
running away hobbling as fast as I can
hobble I'm hobbling as fast as I can
that was a nice maneuver dive dive dive
[Applause]
okay good
have fun with your children and your
bunkers Ness Ness gotta go now gotta go
up here now got a cover here gotta go up
here with less crazy gonna go right here
like here's good here's real good right
here Oh that doors good that door really
airs hard too crazy
now I don't know how hearten I don't
know how far I am from the end of this I
got a bum leg so I don't know what the
endings gonna be all right I'm gonna
stop it here if I made a horrible error
in the endings actually just like right
next year I apologize but right now I'm
alright I'm gonna add it yourself
thank you guys so much for watching
click the annotation more scary games
that I've done and as always I will se
you in the next video
[Music]
seems like the noises happen more in the
dark but I've turned my flashlight
what this what did I get
boom my notes for activating the gods
head
so